like when we're talking about the
mcdonald's the taco bells the burger
kings the wendy's in and outs all that
this this give me your like top five
fast food chains one to five
[Music]
i can't do i can't do the proper order
okay
but chick-fil-a
will chick-fil-a be number one i don't i
i can't do the problem okay okay okay
okay no order chick-fil-a no order for
chick-fil-a
for one and forever bro mcdonald's is
always a little classic i don't give a
[ __ ] if you don't eat the [ __ ] now cause
it's nasty no no no let me say this [ __ ]
cause i i say this [ __ ] all the time
mcdonald's is fire as [ __ ]
if it wasn't so [ __ ] fire it wouldn't
be the biggest [ __ ] in the world the
[ __ ] is fire
is it good for you are they in greek it
tastes good that's it's if it wasn't so
[ __ ] good it wouldn't be the biggest
[ __ ] in the world they got their own
coca-cola there bruh
their coke tastes different than all the
coke in the world
all right mcdonald's we got to put some
respect over mcdonald's be out here
getting disrespected bro i'll pull up
with that [ __ ] give me a double
cheeseburger give me the mcdouble put
french fries inside of the burger extra
ketchup give me the spicy mcchicken
[Music]
i just spent two two dollars
and i'm on
make it big sense and get the orange
high c in the high seas he's about to
say it you took it out of my mouth they
brought him back they brought it they
brought it back they knew what they was
doing they knew they was [ __ ] bugging
when they took that [ __ ] off the menu
bro all right real [ __ ] so
chick-fil-a mcdonald's um
[Music]
believe it or not
i grew up it was a wendy's in my hood
what is this fire
wendy's spicy chicken nuggets yup
fire fire get a frosty frog man frosty
on a hot summer day big umph put some
fries in that [ __ ] man you ever you
ever put dip your fries in the frosting
i haven't bro i to be honest bro i
really been trying to lay off like the
fat i'm getting too big i'm not talking
about now i'm someone in life you've
never you never did the fries at the
front but but i eat my fries with my
frosting i dip it in there all right but
it's the it's
you eat some fries and then
chew them up and then before you swallow
before all the fries down the throat you
put some ice cream back in there and
that [ __ ] tastes so good but i never
just blatantly ate it like that
the wendy's uh chili's the movie
man i will say taco bell but they [ __ ]
up my stomach
last time i was in l.a man i had a real
bad stomach ache bro
so taco bell
taco bell i really got i ain't feeling
them right now so i'm just leaving my um
[Music]
i never really seen like no arby's here
you [ __ ] with harvey i love orbeez
i love orbeez we got the meats
and everyone hates on armies everybody
everyone says it's [ __ ] yo my boy uh pun
i just saw they were arguing on twitter
saying black people don't eat orbeez man
they capping bro let me tell you
something [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] my baby
mama i gotta stop calling my baby mama
[ __ ] my girl her mama got mad at that
and my momma cut it to me about that
like stop calling her yo [ __ ]
listen
orbeez my girl you know cause arby's
just like
they got them curly fries the curly
fries my [ __ ] with the horsey sauce oh
i like the arby sauce that beef and
cheddar all that [ __ ] melted cheese
man
see i [ __ ] with arby's arby's is a dark
horse for sure because nobody talks
about arby's thanks they really got the
meats thanks and the chicken sliders
they sliders go dumb [ __ ] and they're
like a dollar
get the ham and cheese
who's holding down the five spot
i'm a flint [ __ ] bro i'm a michigan
[ __ ] okay
and this franchise was made in michigan
and
rosa parks was about to get put out of
her apartment
and the owner
of this franchise
pay her rent
up until she died
little caesars
five dollars
and by the way
little caesar's pizza
is better
than pizza hut and dominoes that's for
sure
when you go to flint i'm gonna take you
to get a stramboli [ __ ] you ever ate
one of them no yeah that's real flint
[ __ ] bro see see people think about
michigan they think about detroit right
but no
you gotta go to
40 you got to go 45 minutes north
okay
will you hop off [ __ ]
when you hop off that plane and
metropolitan mm-hmm go go go go 45
minutes north to look to a little town
called flint
get you some [ __ ] little caesars and
let me tell you we get you some
[ __ ] life familia [ __ ]
all right get you get you some life
familia
get you some uh
get you some uh get you some yayas
get you some halo burger get you some
big johns that's real flint [ __ ]